bye
it is in this dead being then that the
mental processes and specific functions
of the brain would have to display their
outer reality a reality however which is
still in the individual himself
for the relation of those processes and
functions to the skull which as a dead
being does not have spirit dwelling
within it there presents itself in the
first instance the the external
mechanical relation established above so
that the organs proper and these are in
the brain here press the skull out
around there widen or flatten it or in
whatever other way one cares to
represent this action on it
being itself a part of the organism it
must indeed be credited as in the case
of every bone with a living spontaneous
formative activity so that from this
point of view
it is rather the skull that on its part
presses on the brain and fixes its outer
boundary
and it is better able to do this being
the harder
but in that case the same relation would
still obtain in the determination of
their reciprocal activity for whether
the skull is the determining factor or
the factor determined this would produce
no alteration at all in the the causal
connection except that the skull would
then be made the immediate organ of
self-consciousness because in it cause
would be found the aspect of being for
self
but in point of fact since being for
self as an organic spontaneity is
equally present in both
any causal connection between them is
ruled out
this development of the two however
would be inwardly connected and would be
an organic pre-established harmony which
would leave the two interrelated aspects
free in respect of each other each with
its own shape to which the shape of the
other need not correspond
and still more so
as regards the relation between the
shape and the quality just as the shape
of the grape and the taste of the wine
are mutually independent
but since the determination of being for
cell falls on the side of the brain but
the out of existence on the side of the
skull there is also to be established a
causal connection between them within
the organic unity a necessary relation
between them as external for one another
that is a relation itself external
through which therefore the shape of
each would be determined by the other
this subsection of the observing reasons
section is
subtitled
physiognomy and phrenology and these
were two pseudosciences
of hegel's time that i don't think
there's an awful lot of credence in
today but people were trying to work out
a philosophy of nature that would take
into account
human beings and their individual
characteristics and how they could be
classed into types or or tendencies and
so in section or the paragraph
329 which we're now going to look at
we're seeing the transition from
physiognomy which really has to do with
the entire
body
to looking at phrenology which was much
more specifically located you could say
specifically located in the skull
and what hegel is going to point out to
us now that he's he's got the brain as
being the sort of indwelling seed of
spirit as he called it in the previous
paragraphs as being the organ
in which the spirit uh is able to engage
the rest of the body and thereby
use that as sort of a tool to engage the
the rest of the world
what we're going to see is the the
looking at the connection between the
skull
something that we can actually observe
and the brain which we can observe right
and cut somebody's head open and take a
look around inside but you can't really
tell quite so much of what's going on
now in in the present of course we have
other
means of access to the brain we know
quite a bit more about it than they did
in hegel's time so you have to kind of
remember that as we're working through
this this is from
over two centuries ago so hegel says
that um it is in this dead being what's
the dead being the caput more to him
that he talked about in the last
paragraph the skull
that the mental processes and specific
functions of the brain right the what's
going on as spiritual realities mental
uh you know in and spiritual in german
geistia right
would have to display their outer
reality and this is a reality however
which is still in the individual himself
so the idea there
that's that's underlying phrenology
is that we can examine the skull and
thereby get to know something about the
individual why
because the brain in some way
determines the skull the brain is what
we're really after the brain is where
all the interesting stuff is happening
but we have to look at the the skull on
the outside and then really you know you
probably have to shave the person's head
or find some way to get a hold of that
skull by itself a lot of the work that
was being done was looking at cadavers
skulls
so he goes on and he says um the
relation of those processes and
functions to the skull which is a dead
being does not have spirit dwelling
within it
presents itself in the first instance
the
external mechanical relation established
above
so that the organs proper
these are in the brain
right the parts of the brain
press outward on the skull
this is part of the idea behind
phrenology that because of the way in
which the brain develops it's going it's
going to push parts of the skull outward
and if they don't develop perhaps you
know that part of the skull will be
recessed inward so you know for example
if the frontal lobe is really important
in cognition
and you know use of language and other
higher order faculties then if
somebody's got kind of a squished in
front of their head you should be able
to surmise that they're not very capable
in that way they're whatever capacities
they have aren't really developed but if
they got a big old you know noggin uh
protruding out in front this is why you
see so many literary descriptions of the
great foreheads of people because this
idea that well you know the brain is
pushing the the skull out so the bigger
forehead you are the the smarter you
must be
there really isn't
that much to that as as we know um but
this is you know the way some of the
science of the time was conceptualizing
things so he says
um
the organs proper these are in the brain
here press the skull out around there
widen or flatten it or in whatever way
one cares to represent this action on it
hegel is not buying into this
hagel's saying this is the way in which
people who are into this way of of
trying to observe individuality
human individuality
are making sense of things they're
saying that the skull pushes or or
perhaps even doesn't push or flattens or
whatever it's going to do
the parts of the skull so the skull then
is what a reflection
of the interior reality of the person's
brain that means that it's a it's a
reflection
exterior reflection
of the
geistika the spiritual reality
of the individual which cannot be just
observed directly remember that this
this entire section
is observing reason right so this is
part of the much larger reason section
this is you know we've traced this long
path through the beginnings of observing
reason you know looking at living beings
uh trying to make sense out of
individuality psychological laws now
we're getting down to the really
nitty-gritty this is an attempt to do so
so he says
being itself a part of the organism
the skull must indeed be credited as in
the case of every bone with a living
spontaneous formative activity so that
from this point of view it's rather the
skull that on its part presses on the
brain and fixes its outer boundary and
here hegel makes a joke hegel doesn't
make a lot of jokes so when he does
it's good to point them out he says it's
better able to do this being the harder
i didn't say it was a funny joke but it
is you know at least it's funny for for
me he's saying
look if if we want to say that one thing
influences the other when it comes to
this i mean the skull is in fact a bone
so there's
growth happening within it then why
wouldn't the skull press upon the brain
why would the brain be pushing outward
on the skull it's not like the brain
really is a muscle or anything like that
so
you know he's going to talk a little bit
later of a pre-established harmony and
that's the way we might think of the
real
relation
at least to some degree between the
brain and the skull in a normally
growing
human being you know starting as a baby
baby's got those giant heads compared to
the rest of their body but their skull
has got some soft spots and it gets
bigger and bigger and bigger to make up
for the space that's going to be
occupied by the brain but it's not like
the brain is actually pushing the skull
outward hegel's saying look if that's
what you think why not just think of the
skull as the one that's like confining
the brain
so he goes on and he says
in that case the same relation would
still obtain in the determination of
their reciprocal activity
here he is pointing out something really
important
so phrenology as a science
if it is indeed a science and hegel
doesn't think that it really is
has to
give us
some sort of intelligible relation
between these two factors the skull
and the brain
and he's saying it fails to do so
because maybe you know we could
understand or imagine
some sort of relation between them that
has to do with certain parts of the
brain being more active or being more
developed and then pushing the skull
well why not think of it the other way
the fact that we can think about it
either way
shows us that there's
a lack of real causality there
that there's something like an
arbitrariness
to what we're imagining
so he goes on and he says
whether the skull is the determining
factor or the factor determined this
would produce no alteration at all in
the causal connection except that then
the skull
would be made the immediate organ of
self-consciousness why because then the
skull would be being for itself
which is what spirit is which is
what we've been after this entire time
trying to observe trying to make sense
of
but we've already said that the skull is
something at least in respect to the
brain and certainly spirit
it's a dead thing it's the the kaput
more to him the dead head uh in in uh
many respects right
so
that's not going to work
he says that
the skull would be made the the
immediate organ of self-consciousness
because in it
cause
would be found the aspect of being in
its being for self but in point of fact
he says since being for herself
is as an organic spontaneity is equally
present in both any causal connection
between them is ruled out what is he
saying there
well we already know that the brain this
is from the previous paragraphs is how
the being for self
of spirit
has its reflective activity that engages
corporeally causally with the rest of
the world but specifically through its
own body
now we're also saying that the skull is
being for self and we're saying that
these two are somehow connected with
each other and we're not sure which
direction the causality goes
in this case hegel's not spelling this
out very well he's sort of skipping
steps here we would have two beings for
self that are somehow connected together
uh and you would say well what's what's
going on here there's kind of a
redundancy isn't there
so he goes on and he says not only does
this rule any causal connection out
he says that this development of the two
would be inwardly connected
and here he talks about an organic
pre-established harmony
now what would be the problem with that
it wouldn't explain anything to us would
it
you wouldn't provide us with any sort of
intelligibility
which then we could use as observing
reason to make sense out of the
individuality that's supposed to be
connected with this noggin
the whole head and connect it
specifically with this uh
this this you know contained brain
within the skull if it's just a
pre-established harmony
there's really no interconnection
causally and phrenology is based around
the idea that there is a causal relation
between the interiority the i.e the
brain
and the exteriority of the skull what
hegel is going to call the display of
outer reality
so if we have a pre-established harmony
that's not going to get us what we need
if we can't establish which way the
causality goes that's not going to get
us what we need it's starting to look as
if phrenology
as a science is inherently problematic
so he goes on and he says
this pre-established harmony would leave
the two interrelated aspects free in
relation
of each other each with its own shape to
which the shape of the other need not
correspond
and here he's got a really interesting
simile
or or metaphor here an analogy actually
he says um
still more so is regards the relation
between the shape and the quality just
as the shape of the grape and the taste
of the wine are mutually independent now
there's a lot of things when it comes to
wine and when it comes to grapes that
are not mutually independent of each
other right when we're talking about
wine tasting one of the key terms is
terroir and that means you know where it
was grown and all the environmental
conditions you know remember back to
hagel talking about uh environmental
laws
and
you know a really well uh
informed and and trained connoisseur of
wine can tell you quite a bit about
the wine and the grapes specifically by
the taste of it
but it doesn't really matter what shape
the grapes are
i mean as a matter of fact if if we
could conceive of them as being cubes or
something like that
it probably wouldn't make a hell of a
lot of difference now would it
i mean maybe you know who knows we we
could this would be an interesting thing
for experiment
well it's the same way for the skull
and the brain
i mean you know if you look at it
the skull and the brain do kind of fit
in well together but there's some
slippage between them isn't there
and you can't conclude an awful lot
about the specific
organs well let's not say organs let's
say
sub-organs within the brain
based solely on possessing the the dead
skull
i mean people did this
you know they would take skulls and fill
them up with ball bearings and measure
how many it took to fill them up and
well you've got more ball bearings so
you must have a bigger brain so you must
have been smarter this is the sort of
thing that pseudoscience was doing in
the 19th century and also into the 20th
century they take all sorts of
measurements with calipers sometimes
they do this on living people they'd you
know feel around and oh you've got a
bump there you must be a criminal type
oh you've got this kind of ridge here oh
you must be very intellectual or you're
a poet or any of these sorts of things
hegel is
you might say at this point he's going
along with the phrenologist you know
giving them as much rope as they need in
order to hang them which is what he's
going to do by the end of this this
section but here he's stressing look
this relationship that's supposed to
hold that's really key for phrenology is
not is not really working out so well
so since the determination of being for
self falls on the side of the brain but
that of existence does i'm on the side
of the skull there is also to be
established a causal connection between
them within the organic unity within the
the
the organic unity i suppose would be the
head or the body as such
so
so there's a necessary relation
between them as external for one another
i.e a relation itself external through
which
therefore the shape of each would be
determined by the other and now he's not
endorsing this this is what phrenology
is sort of forcing itself into the
corner uh of believing in order to make
any of this work so there has to be some
sort of reciprocal relation of causality
between them maybe the brain pushes
outward maybe the skull pushes inward
somehow they affect each other that's
what you need
in order to get this entire project of
phrenology as a specific type of
physiognomy
off the ground
however as regards the determination in
which the organ of self-consciousness
would act causally on the opposite
aspect
all sorts of things can be said
for what is in question is the
constitution of a cause which is
considered in regard to its indifferent
outer existence its shape and size a
cause whose inner being and being for
self are to be precisely of a kind which
does not concern the immediate or outer
existence
the organic spontaneous formation of the
skull is in the first place indifferent
to any mechanical influence exerted on
it and the relationship of these two
relations since the former is a relating
of itself to itself is just this very
indefiniteness and unboundedness
furthermore even if the brain received
into itself the distinctions of spirit
as existential distinctions and were a
plurality of internal organs each
occupying a different space
it would be left undetermined whether a
spiritual feature would according as it
was originally stronger or weaker
be bound to possess in the first case a
more expanded brain organ or in the
latter case a more contracted brain
organ or even the other way about but it
is contradictory to nature for the brain
to be such a plurality of internal
organs for nature gives the moments of
the notion and existence of their own
and therefore puts the fluid simplicity
of organic life clearly on one side and
its articulation and division with its
distinctions clearly on the other so
that in the way they are to be grasped
here they display themselves as
particular anatomical things
similarly with the question whether the
development of the brain would enlarge
or diminish the organ whether it would
make it coarser and thicker or finer
from the fact that it remains
undetermined how the cause is
constituted it is equally left
undetermined how the effect is produced
in the skull whether it is an enlarging
or a narrowing and falling in of the
latter
when this influence is defined as it
were more imposingly as a stimulation it
is still undetermined whether this takes
place by swelling like the effect of a
cantharidis plaster or by shriveling
like the effect of vineyard vinegar
all views of this kind can be supported
by plausible grounds
for the organic relation which just as
much plays a part
accommodates one view as readily as
another and is indifferent to all of
this cleverness
here in paragraph 330 hegel is following
up on what he was just talking about
in paragraph 329 the the relation the
causal relation between the brain on the
one hand
as he's called it the indwelling suit of
spirit where where things are supposed
to be happening because it's it's being
for itself right it's got this reflexive
relation to itself
as well as to the body and the outer the
skull the the the bone as he's gonna a
little bit later say spirit is turned
into a bone
by by phrenology
and he says okay let's begin by thinking
about what the causal relation is
supposed to be
here between the inner
and the outer between the brain and the
skull let's say that the brain really
does
in some way affect the shape of the
skull it pushes it out or doesn't push
it out so it kind of squishes in or
flattens it or whatever is going on
right having a big old brain gives you a
big old forehead or something along
those lines
so he says as regards the determination
in which the organ of self-consciousness
that's the that's the brain
would act causally on the opposite
aspect that is the skull
all sorts of things can be said now that
is a very pregnant thing to say all
sorts of things can be said it's sort of
like when somebody asks you a question
like well what do you think about that
person say
oh you know there's a lot of different
ways in which one might construe their
actions what are you saying you're
saying perhaps that you don't know or
there's multiple perspectives possible
and all of them are equally valid or
perhaps you don't actually want to say
anything about the person but here hegel
is saying yeah phrenology you could do
it a lot of different ways it's sort of
like you know a coloring book to take a
completely you know different analogy
you can fill in any way you like as a
matter of fact you don't even have to
stay within the lines you can add in
your own lines you can draw things that
aren't there in the coloring book that's
that's all fine for coloring right and
the same thing is happening with the
relation between the brain
and the the
you know the bodily aspect of it the the
skull the external thing that we can
look at
in phrenology
so he goes on and he says what is in
question is the constitution of a cause
which is considered in regard to its
indifferent outer existence shape and
size
a cause whose inner being
and being for self are to to be
precisely of a kind which does not
concern the immediate or outer existence
so if we're thinking in terms of what
the brain is supposed to be doing not
just in terms of the brain as being a
bunch of cells that are you know all
glommed together in a certain way
although that's quite fascinating as
well right
but if we think about what in hegelian
understanding of the relationship of
consciousness to the body the brain
is supposed to be doing the brain is
supposed to be where spirit is carrying
out its activities so that doesn't look
like something that is a bone you know
however cool bone may be and however
well developed and interesting in its
own right when we put it under the
microscope
it's quite fascinating actually
it doesn't come anywhere close to what
it is that makes a human being
a
human being a rational animal
engaged in meaningful action living in
culture all these other sorts of things
that we can say
so he goes on and he says
the organic spontaneous formation of the
skull is indifferent to any mechanical
influence exerted on it now that's not
quite true i mean you know we know we
can bind people's skulls and their heads
turn out looking kind of strange from
our perspective the cultures that did
that uh you apparently saw that as a
sign of beauty or power um so it is
possible to to you know make the the
skull look different ways you know
cradle boarding is another prime example
of that but
that doesn't seem to affect the brain
over much
in part because the brain is a really
peculiar sort of organ as we'll get to
in a moment here
so he says the the organic spontaneous
formation of the skull the way the skull
develops is indifferent to any
mechanical influence and the
relationship of these two relations
since the former is talking about the
way the skull develops here is a
relating of itself to itself
is just this very indefiniteness and
unboundedness and then he says
let's put that aside
here's something even more interesting
to think about
now here hegel is going to say something
that
when you've learned some anatomy and
physiology you're probably going to
disagree with and so we have to put this
into a proper context
so he says
even if the brain received into itself
the distinctions of spirit as
existential distinctions now he's not
that's a little bit of a mistranslation
there he's talking about the the being
of the the brain
and we're a plurality of internal organs
each occupying a different space
okay let's stop right there for a second
because that is indeed
how we often represent to ourselves the
development of the brain we say that you
know just for an example uh looking at
the evolution of the human brain we talk
about
a uh
earlier inheritance from
uh
you know previous types of existence uh
you know a reptilian brain which is
concerned with you know the fight the
fight and flight response and and things
along those lines if i remember right i
think smell is oriented towards that
part of the the brain as well and then
we have the million brain you know which
makes us capable of among other things
higher emotions like you like caring for
each other and feeling affection
and then we have the distinctively human
part of the brain
which um you know for example gives us
the capacity to do
pretty complex
and um
things that we take for granted
linguistic operations right
and so we can say that there are parts
of the brain that do certain things
that said as it turns out we find out
sometimes people
lose those parts of the brain and other
parts of the brain eventually
take over for them
so there is you know what people have
come to call nowadays it's kind of a
catchphrase
neuroplasticity right and i'm not
talking about this in the sense uh you
know where the self-help stuff is i'm
talking about the the fact that the
brain
is in in many respects this organ that
can can reconfigure
itself it seems in relation to its body
so that it can get certain things done
so hegel probably uh is off base here
right and saying well uh if the brain
you know if we assumed that the brain
had distinctions of spirit as
existential distinctions or plurality of
internal organs each occupying a
different space he said look if you if
you assume that sort of thing the way
those phrenologists do and the
phrenologists at least in that respect
were right
then here's what would happen
he says it would be left undetermined
whether a spiritual feature would
according as it was originally stronger
or weaker be bound to possess in the
first case a more expanded brain organ
or in the latter case a more contracted
brain organ or even the other way about
you know he's relative he's pretty much
right when it comes to that now we can
talk
about other things like the amount of
electro electrical activity observed in
certain parts of the brain we can talk
about how finely the neurons are
connected to each other that in certain
parts of certain people's brains there's
moral neural connections that is
connections between the cells that are
you know if we want to think about sub
organs they are the tiniest little sub
organs they're the basic unit
of of the the wet wear that is our brain
we can talk about that but there is no
necessary causal connection
between a part of the brain
being in a gross way
big enough that it would push out on
part of the skull and you know like like
a rivet you know pushing that bump out
and that's the way that the
phrenologists were thinking about the
way that the brain developed so the idea
would be well you know you've got more
linguistic function than somebody else
we take the guys who put together
dictionaries and then we'll look at
their heads and i'll bet you there's
going to be one part of their brain
that's pushing out on the skull and
they'll all have that in common doesn't
turn out to be the case
you know we sometimes find people who
you know their head is kind of pushed in
here on this side i remember a guy like
that when i was in the army and they're
not only is less intelligent than the
rest of us
because you know the brain can the brain
is pretty malleable different parts can
can show up in different ways so hegel's
saying there's no inherent connection
even on the hypothesis which turns out
to be a true hypothesis that there are
sub organs within the brain
there's no in there's no inherent
connection between the way that
sub organ looks and whether it's more or
less developed in terms of its size in
terms of something that would be gross
in that way there could be a much finer
like i said tissue of connection within
there might be a lot more activity
happening in that part of the brain but
that doesn't like you know push out an
entire part of the part of the head so
he says um
here's where he he
you gotta
interpret what he's saying with a little
bit of grain of salt it's contradictory
to nature for the brain to be such a
plurality of internal organs for nature
gives the moments of the notion and
existence of their own and therefore
puts the fluid simplicity of organic
life clearly on one side and it's
articulation and division with its
distinctions clearly on the other so
that in the way they're grasped here
they display themselves as particular
anatomical things is is he saying that
because the brain is the indwelling seed
of spirit as he's called it before that
the brain is just one sort of continuum
full of neurons or you know connections
or
maybe you conceived of in terms of the
lobes or or things along those lines
you know
he he is right in a sense that the brain
is not simply reducible
insofar as it's a living person's brain
a person who actually has
consciousness that's somehow working
through the brain as as its organ it's
not reducible to just a bunch of you
know plug-in parts that you can connect
up with each other uh you know sort of
like legos or or like you know an
erector set or or you know a circuit
board or something like that
but he is wrong in thinking that the
brain doesn't differentiate itself into
sub organs and that that couldn't be
part of the way in which
geist or spirit works
so if we put that aside and sometimes
you know we do have to say hegel seems
to be wrong about this let's put that
aside what is the main point that he's
after here
he says
even if we accepted that right
he says similarly with the question of
whether the development of the brain
would enlarge or diminish the organ
whether it would make it coarser or
thicker or
finer what's he getting at so let's say
we do assume that there are these you
know divisions or distinctions within
the brain which does seem to be the case
right then
what we have to say is
do these translate
into areas of the skull
can we look at the skull
the external thing
and figure out
whether
more development or less development
of those
parts those divisions those distinctions
those those sub organs those organic
things
whether that would actually be reflected
in the skull
hegel says
i guess it could be but there's no
reason
why
they would be associated in the way that
you the phrenologist take them to be i
mean if we're going to proceed on this
hypothesis we don't know whether
development of a part pushes the skull
in or draws the pushes the skull out or
draws the skull in or makes it flat or
makes it round or we don't we don't
really know any of these things so
euphrenologists are kind of making it up
as you go along
remember back a few uh passages before
sort of like the
uh you know housewife who says yes it
always rains when i do my laundry she's
generalizing from a very small amount of
cases and probably obscuring the
evidence as she does so or you know so
you don't have to pick on the housewife
the trader who also says something like
that whenever i go to market it always
rains for me right
something similar is going on with the
phrenologist who is making these cases
so he's got a funny example here he says
when this influence is defined
as it were more imposingly as a
stimulation right we use different
terminology to make it seem like we're
talking about something real
because it's undetermined whether this
takes place by swelling like when you
put a cantharitis plaster on something
that would be an irritant and you know
make you swell up
or by shriveling like the effect of
vinegar right some very prosaic stuff
here he says here's the key
all views of this kind can be supported
by plausible grounds plausible grounds
we'll come back to that a second for the
organic relation which just as much
plays a part accommodates one view as
readily as another and is indifferent to
all of this cleverness
so plausible is not quite the same thing
as necessity or a causal relation right
we can come up with all sorts of
plausible explanations for things but we
want something more than mere
plausibility
that unfortunately is what phrenology is
not going to supply us with or anything
analogous
to phrenology in the way that it
understands the brain in relation to
something
external